("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Insomnia" by Cartel Beats)
Early morning
workout in Houston.
Saturday of the Super Bowl.
Got some meetings.
Cops broke up my
meet up last night.
- Everyone out
of the street now.
Go that way.
- Was crazy.
Thanks to the Houston
police for keeping me safe.
Jordan, what's
going on with me shoulder?
What are we doing?
- So, we're working right now on
building up the overall strength
and endurance of it but
beforehand you
had a slight tear.
So basically everything we're
doing is to work around the
slight tear while building up
the strength and endurance.
- Rare situation where the
left is stronger than the right.
Somebody just DM'd me about the
Joe Rogan podcast and he said,
you know,
great observation, great guy.
Very nice note.
Said, you know, ying yang.
You've got the yang.
You're competitive but that
thing that Joe was talking about
with your daughter and the
basketball and this maybe you need to
look at the ying and yang.
You got to look at both sides.
I don't think people understand.
I look at both
sides quite a bit.
I live both sides quite a bit.
I'm pulling from both sides
quite a bit but here's the
difference when I'm on
the field all-in one way.
Like everybody wants a
micro ying and yang but
that's not how it works.
It's a macro ying and yang.
On the big picture,
super balanced.
But when I'm on the
fucking field competing,
you have to go 100.
Jordan, how do I workout?
- 100% every time.
- That's it and I fucking
hate working out.
But that's the part, you can't
be 50-50 working out,
50-50 in relationships,
50-50 in your escapism,
50-50 in the way you play.
That's why everybody's average.
You have to be
macro ying and yang,
micro all-in one
way or the other.
Right here is good, man.
- Thanks man.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
("Insomnia" by Cartel Beats)
11:30 at night.
Heading to another
meeting right now.
Early days of
VaynerSports Super Bowl.
Some ups, some downs.
You know, real life
stuff but I love it.
I wish we were filming
VaynerMedia early on 'cause we
have plenty of ups and
downs those first two years.
People think it comes
overnight but it just doesn't.
Grinding my ass
off here at Super Bowl.
Not even staying for the game.
Leaving at 7 A.M.
to get home.
I don't need to
watch Pats and that's it.
Just really enjoying it.
I enjoy the grind.
I love the process.
I love that you guys get to
see something from the beginning
when it was nothing.
It was a little seed and you
get to see the tough days.
We've got some coming and
the great days so enjoying it.
Good day with AJ, grinding.
Love the journey my friends.
If I can say anything to you,
love the journey because
("Insomnia" by Cartel Beats)
you'll never get
through the first quarter.
2:18 in the morning, hustled.
Made some stuff happen.
Feel productive.
Feelin' good.
Got it.
Just work, you know?
How'd you get it?
I worked.
if you don't love the journey,